on sait pas très bien ce qu'il a voulu
faire
il est revenu dans le salon
il perdait tellement fort que là il fait
c'est à cet endroit que Hugues va perdre
connaissance puis mourir
seulement il reste deux énigmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Brignogan sur mer en Bretagne
nous sommes dans la nuit du 3 ou 4 juin
2016 François de la Plaza et son épouse
Mireille sont réveillés brutalement par
la sonnerie du téléphone c'est le lundi
matin à 4
h30 de téléphone sonne
à l'autre bout du fil mélissan x c'est
l'ex petit ami de leur fils Hugues de la
Plaza elle appelle depuis les États-Unis
[Musique]
j'ai de mauvaises nouvelles et je l'ai
dit en français
j'ai dit
trois mots qui laissent François sans
voix
son fils unique vient de mourir à
l'autre bout du monde
il est mort
alors là la catastrophe c'est
[Musique]
pas possible
et dans un français approximatif Mélissa
a du mal à expliquer les circonstances
troubles dans lesquelles le jeune
Français est mort
[Musique]
apparemment il a été il avait été tué
à Hugues de la Plaza et pourquoi sa mort
mystérieuse pose tant de questions
voici l'histoire d'une invraisemblable
enquête
et du combat d'un père pour connaître la
vérité sur la mort de son enfant
voir qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
exactement
sur le couteau il y a des tâches de sang
donc c'est l'arme du crime
[Musique]
San Francisco États-Unis nous sommes le
3 juin 2016
dans cet immeuble du centre ville l'un
des habitants de la résidence sort sur
le perron
il fait aussitôt une étrange découverte
un voisin de palier sort de chez lui
pour aller travailler il remarque
d'importantes tâches de sang
[Musique]
partout sur le perron
aussitôt l'homme appelle le sfpidy la
police de San Francisco une fois sur
place les enquêteurs cherchent à savoir
ce qu'il s'est passé
un petit peu comme le Petit Poucet ils
suivent les traces de sang pour arriver
jusqu'à la porte du domicile de
l'appartement duc de la Plaza
mais la porte de l'appartement est
fermée à clé alors les policiers passent
par derrière
[Musique]
et une fois à l'intérieur il découvre un
véritable carnage
[Musique]
il y a du sang au sol quelques objets
sont renversés dans le fond de
l'appartement il trouve le corps de
Hugues de la Plaza
un jeune français de 37 ans
il a trois blessures au total sur le
côté gauche
assez bas au niveau du ventre un peu
plus haut dans l'abdomen et au niveau de
la gorge où il est très sérieusement
touché
que lui est-il arrivé exactement
trop tôt pour le dire une chose est sûre
il ne s'agit pas d'un crime de rôdeur
un téléphone
et puis il y a le portefeuille du jeune
homme qui est retrouvé avec une liasse
de billets de banque
l'appartement est verrouillé de
l'intérieur et toutes les fenêtres sont
fermées
aucune trace d'effraction ni de vol un
corps lardé de coups de couteau la mort
de Hugues de la Plaza et pour l'instant
un mystère
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique en
Bretagne
l'incompréhension est totale
Mireille et François de la Plaza les
parents de Hugues décrivent leur fils
comme un garçon sans histoire
[Musique]
très discret jamais se mettant en avant
c'est pour ça qu'il avait voulu
parce qu'il avait ce contact
facilement
il était très drôle
ingénieur du son de formation Hugues
décide à 28 ans de partir aux États-Unis
pour vivre le rêve américain
il a eu l'idée de partir directement à
New York comme ça ils sont équipés dans
la poche voilà c'est comme ça
[Musique]
et c'est à New York que Hugues va
rencontrer Mélissa
immédiatement c'est le coup de foudre
[Musique]
je me souviens de voir ceci bel homme
dans un bon costume
un petit français comme ça a été sympa
discret elle est le flash tout de suite
et lui aussi ça a marché tout de suite
très bien
et je lui ai proposé qu'on se revoit
nous sommes sortis
le jeune couple est si amoureux que
lorsque Mélissa doit quitter New York
pour San Francisco Hugues n'hésite pas à
la suivre
il a atterri à San Francisco et qu'un
jour après trois semaines il a retrouvé
un autre travail c'était comme on l'a
décrit un million d'ingénieur du son
pendant 5 ans le jeune homme partage sa
vie entre la France et les États-Unis il
semble heureux
même si sa relation avec Mélissa et
parfois tourmenté
[Musique]
on se séparait puis se remettait
ensemble puis on se séparait mais nous
étions vraiment amoureux et puis
finalement bah le couple va se séparer
mais il reste en excellent termes
[Musique]
pour les proches du jeune homme sa mort
est inexplicable
tout s'attendent beaucoup de l'enquête
de la police américaine et ils ne vont
pas tarder à avoir des premières
réponses
[Musique]
à San Francisco l'enquête avant sa grand
pas
en effet la scène de crime va parler
d'abord des éléments déterminants laisse
penser que Hugues de la Plaza était seul
au moment des faits
parce que les gouttes de sang qu'on
retrouve au sol semblent être tombé à la
plomb a priori pas de lutte donc il y a
bien des traces de pas
mais ce ne sont pas celles dues ou des
meurtriers
les traces de pas qu'on a retrouvées
dans le sang
il y a quelqu'un qui a marché dans les
flaques de sang on s'aperçoit que c'est
les pas de Hugues de la Plaza donc là
encore pas d'intervention de d'un tiers
extérieur
dans la cuisine les policiers américains
vont même retrouver ce qu'ils pensent
être l'arme du crime
il retrouve plusieurs couteaux dans
l'évier dont un qui a été nettoyé et qui
va être dans l'esprit des policiers
probablement l'arme du crime
avec une lame comme ça
la lame du couteau aurait donc
bizarrement été nettoyé mais les
policiers remarquent tout de même
quelques légères traces rouges sur le
manche
s'agit-il de traces de sang le couteau
est mis sous scellé
[Musique]
S
après plusieurs heures passées dans
l'appartement les enquêteurs semblent
déjà avoir leur petite idée du scénario
qui a pu se dérouler la veille au soir
et leur intuition va être confirmée en
interrogeant les voisins
[Musique]
dans l'immeuble où vit Hugues de la
Plaza les trois autres appartements sont
occupés
les voisins sont donc interrogés un nain
en fait personne n'a rien entendu sauf
une voisine
gitanjalibuscian vit dans l'appartement
situé juste à côté de celui de Hugues de
la Plaza
elle raconte qu'elle est son mari ont
été réveillés au beau milieu de la nuit
on a entendu une petite souris
[Musique]
en même temps c'est étrange c'est
bizarre et là les bruits se sont arrêtés
le couple affirme alors s'être rendormie
car les bruits avaient cessé
des portes qui claquent au beau milieu
de la nuit mais sans un cri les
enquêteurs ne voient qu'une explication
possible au décès duc de la Plaza une
conclusion pour le moins surprenante
qu'il va maintenant falloir annoncer à
la famille du jeune homme et à ses
proches
[Musique]
5 jours après la mort de leur enfant
François et Mireille de la Plaza
arrivent à San Francisco
il ne parle pas un mot d'anglais alors
Mélissa et un ami de leur fils les
accompagne à la police
[Musique]
nous avons rencontré les policiers et
évidemment il ne s'attendait pas à
entendre ce qu'ils vont entendre
la police on a été extrêmement déçu
[Musique]
la réaction des parents
c'est incompréhensible
il se trouve quelque part
ce qui se passe en plus de la manière
dont il a été tué trois coups de couteau
bon
le suicide de faire
c'est là où on a compris qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui allait pas
que Hugues c'était suscité
les proches du jeune Français tombent
des nues comment leur fils et amis
a-t-il pu se suicider de trois coups de
couteau
mais les policiers avancent des
arguments
d'abord ils affirment que Hugues étaient
seuls chez lui
parce que la porte est verrouillée de
l'intérieur
et la porte sur le jardin était
verrouillée
il y a donc pas de traces de fractions
et on a été volé et l'arme du crime est
à l'intérieur donc pour la police il y a
pas l'ombre d'un doute c'est un suicide
selon la police américaine Hugues de la
Plaza était donc seul chez lui et il se
serait donné la mort à l'aide d'un
couteau celui souvenez-vous qui a été
saisi dans l'évier de la cuisine
[Musique]
et puis preuve ultime pour les
enquêteurs quelques lignes griffonnées
par la victime sur un carnet retrouvé à
son domicile
il s'agit en fait d'une citation de
Gandhi
[Musique]
rien la citation de
mourir demain voilà il s'est flingué
contre au contraire c'est là la vie
de cacher ce meurtre sous le tapis
ça comme un suicide et terminer le reste
[Musique]
aux États-Unis l'affaire Hugues de la
Plaza est classé avec les affaires
nonélucidés
[Musique]
François le père de la victime et
furieux il décide alors de mener sa
propre enquête pour connaître enfin la
vérité sur la mort de son fils
[Musique]
en interrogeant les amis de son fils
François va très vite trouver des
éléments qui ne collent pas avec la
thèse du suicide
d'abord Hugh était loin d'être en
[Musique]
dépressions
moto rendez-vous avec un copain un
copain français qui travaille à Los
Angeles qui est en relation avec lui la
tête de Fifi des
d'autant que Hugues fourmille et de
projet et n'avait aucun problème
d'argent bien au contraire
[Musique]
il avait envie de changer d'air il a une
envisagé de partir en Argentine il avait
été en Argentine la Buenos Aires il
avait regardé ce qu'il pouvait faire
là-bas il était il était plus ou moins
prêt à partir
[Musique]
vous croyez que c'est un métier
les proches de la victime se demandent
alors si les policiers américains ont
sérieusement fait leur travail car en se
plongeant dans le dossier de Topsy
François de la Plaza va découvrir que
plusieurs
erreurs grossières ont été commises
dans le rapport du médecin légiste elle
stipule que Hugues de la Plaza est
circoncis or Hugues de la Plaza n'était
pas circoncis et ce n'est pas la seule
erreur
ils disent que
74 la musique
et le père de la victime n'est pas au
bout de ses surprises
souvenez-vous le matin du crime une mare
de sang est découverte sur le perron de
l'immeuble
or ces traces de sang capitale pour
l'enquête vont être effacés à 10h ou 11h
les pompiers ont passé au karcher tout
le sang qui avait sur les le perron
même que les analyses soient financés oh
mon Dieu pourquoi faire une chose
pareille
mais il y a plus incroyable encore le
couteau à steak dans l'évier de la
cuisine serait selon la police l'arme
avec laquelle Hulk se serait lui-même
poignardé
alors comment expliquer que la lame de
ce couteau était retrouvée propre
comme si elle avait été nettoyée
la police s'attache à dire que il se
suicide et ensuite dans un souci de
propreté alors qu'il y a du sang partout
dans l'appartement il va nettoyer son
couteau avant d'aller mourir là on est
au confins de la folie
des blessures avec un couteau le laver
le remettre dans l'évier ça n'a aucun
sens
est-ce par mauvaise foi ou par manque de
moyens François de la Plaza ne va pas
tarder à trouver des réponses à ces
questions
face au manquement de la police et pour
découvrir la vérité sur la mort de son
fils François de la Plaza décide alors
de faire appel à un professionnel
[Musique]
et si il est connu dans la baie de San
Francisco c'est que depuis 25 ans il dit
avoir enquêté avec son cabinet sur plus
de 5000 affaires
[Musique]
lorsque François de la Plaza la pelle le
détective n'hésite pas un instant
bien sûr c'était une affaire
intéressante et internationale dès le
début il y avait des problèmes il n'y
avait pas d'armes et des policiers
ça n'avait aucun sens et c'était très
intéressant pour moi
pour John Murphy ce genre d'affaires
classées est assez fréquent aux
États-Unis et pour cause
vous savez si on classe l'affaire si
elle est retirée de la liste des
homicides et replacer sur la liste des
affaires non élucidées et bien au lieu
d'avoir 80 monstres cette année on en a
que 70 juifs
[Musique]
je pense que la police a classé la mort
en suicide car il comptait sur plusieurs
éléments
vous n'avez pas de famille aux
États-Unis il était de nationalité
française
mais il y a une autre raison pour
peut-être expliquer pourquoi la police
américaine a classé en suicide ce qui
ressemble en tout point à un meurtre
par an dans la salle principale
il était en train de préparer son
élection en tant que gouverneur de
Californie
le détective John Murphy se met au
travail
il reprend l'enquête depuis le départ
et ce qu'il va découvrir va conforter la
piste du meurtre
[Musique]
en interrogeant les proches de Hugues
John Murphy le détective découvre que la
victime avait quelques peu changé depuis
sa séparation avec Mélissa le jeune
homme semblait être devenu addict au
sexe
avec des femmes autant que possible
et ce n'est pas tout le détective
découvre que ces derniers temps il
arrivait à Hugues de bois et parfois
même de se droguer chose que ses parents
ignoraient
un peu trop là j'étais très surpris il
découvre que son fils de temps en temps
sa alcoolisait lourdement il découvre
également qu'il lui arrivait aussi de
prendre quelques rails de cocaïne pour
prolonger ses fêtes
alcool conquête amoureuse autant de
pistes possibles que la police ne semble
pas avoir prise en compte et que John ne
détective va s'attacher à explorer une à
une
[Musique]
bijoux après la mort du jeune Français
le détective décide de se rendre sur les
lieux du crime
et pour lui les traces de sang sur le
perron permettent d'échafauder un
premier scénario
Hugues rentrez chez lui quand il a été
sauvagement agressé
moi je crois qu'il a été poignardé à
l'extérieur juste ici
quelque part entre ici et là
il y avait une grosse tache de sang
et ensuite
elles existent ces traces de sang et il
faut les prendre en considération pour
essayer de comprendre comment les choses
se sont passées
selon John Murphy le soir de sa mort
Hugues de la Plaza est rentré à pied
d'une soirée passée dans un bar situé à
une dizaine de minutes de chez lui
[Musique]
selon lui il est tout à fait possible
qu'en chemin le jeune homme est fait une
mauvaise rencontre
entre le bas
si vous voulez vous faire tuer ou faire
baisser acheter ou vendre de la drogue
c'est laquelle
[Musique]
de la vie pour rentrer chez lui ce n'est
pas un endroit très sûr
donc il a peut-être essayé de trouver de
la drogue bien qu'ils ont envie pas
vraiment
de suivre jusqu'à chez lui et le pouvoir
pour le détective une chose est sûre
Hugues a été agressé devant son domicile
c'est aussi la conviction du père de la
victime et voici selon lui comment les
choses se seraient passées
on frappait à l'extérieur
il ouvre la porte il rentre
une trace de doigt en haut de la porte
il pousse la porte comme ça elle se
ferme automatiquement et il ferme le
verrou
est allé dans la cuisine
on sait pas très bien ce qu'il a voulu
faire
qui est revenu dans le salon
il perdait tellement fort que là
c'est à cet endroit que Hugues va perdre
connaissance puis mourir
seulement il reste deux énigmes
si Hugues est victime d'une agression
devant chez lui pourquoi va-t-il dans la
cuisine au fond de l'appartement au lieu
d'appeler les secours américain est
composé le fameux 911
[Musique]
quand il est rentré dans son appartement
il n'a pas appelé l'escouade
que s'il avait été tué par quelqu'un il
aurait aussitôt appelé les secours
pour le détective ici Hugues n'a pas
appelé les secours cela tient uniquement
à la gravité de ses blessures
la quantité de sang qui l'a perdu dans
la surprise qui a suivi l'agression la
rendue incapable de penser est-ce que je
dois appeler
je pense que 3 minutes c'est le maximum
de temps pour réagir surtout avec sa
blessure à la gorge
et puis il reste à élucider un autre
mystère
[Musique]
si Hugues a été agressé devant chez lui
alors pourquoi les voisins n'ont rien
entendu
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas de bruit d'agression ou
quoi que ce soit cela
ont entendu un peu d'agitation
étrange en effet
[Musique]
grâce aux éléments d'enquête recueillis
par le détective
puisque la police américaine a
définitivement opté pour la thèse du
suicide
[Musique]
IDE François de la Plaza le père de la
victime a une idée
il décide de mettre son affaire sur la
place publique et pour cela il a une
alliée de poids
Mélissa l'ex petit ami de son fils
journaliste de formation
[Musique]
François était souvent à la tête d'une
manifestation ou en train de faire une
déclaration devant la mairie pour
réclamer justice
on a commencé à avoir des journalistes
qui ont écrit des papiers
accablants donc l'affaire est devenue
publique
malgré le battage médiatique la police
américaine ne réagit toujours pas
l'enquête reste au point mort
[Musique]
six mois après la mort de Hugues de la
Plaza François son père doit se rendre à
l'évidence la police américaine ne
l'aidera pas
l'homme rentre en France et c'est là que
l'enquête va connaître un incroyable
rebondissement car le Breton n'a pas dit
son dernier mot
auprès du tribunal à Paris
trouver un avocat bon boum faire des
démarches quoi
et fait rarissime une commission
rogatoire internationale est ordonnée
l'enquête est relancée
du juge d'instruction et deux officiers
de police judiciaire sont donc envoyés à
San Francisco
[Musique]
une victoire pour les proches de Hugues
de la Plaza
est arrivé un an après la mort de Louise
on était tous très contents que les
policiers français arrivent parce que la
police américaine n'avait pas pris la
faire au sérieux
des caméras des journalistes il y avait
des conférences de presse
c'est la première fois dans les annales
la ville que ça a été ça a été fait donc
c'était c'est une occasion extrêmement
rare
habituelle pour les États-Unis qui
gouvernement étranger et besoins de
venir pour faire une investigation
capacité dont ce serait d'ailleurs bien
passé Antonio gasillas l'inspecteur
américain qui était en charge de
l'affaire
[Musique]
des policiers français qui viennent d'un
petit pays qui s'est même poussé là qui
vient ici
patauger dans son enquête ce n'est pas
lui faire plaisir
la police américaine voit d'un tel
mauvaise oeil l'arrivée de leur collègue
français qu'elle ne va pas leur
faciliter le travail
[Musique]
en arrivant on voulait voir le dossier
au département
du dossier français
une fois le dossier en main les
policiers français vont enfin pouvoir
commencer à travailler lorsque les
policiers français commencent leurs
investigations il s'aperçoit de
l'étendue des dégâts du travail des
policiers américains
les enquêteurs français se demandent
alors pourquoi autant de questions sont
restées sans réponse
comment expliquer ces tâches de sang
dans l'appartement mais aussi sur le
perron
pourquoi les portes étaient-elles
verrouillées de l'intérieur
pourquoi les voisins n'ont rien entendu
quel est l'arme du crime et surtout qui
pouvait en vouloir à ce jeune français
de 37 ans
[Musique]
les policiers français décident de
reprendre toute l'enquête à zéro d'abord
ils établissent une liste de suspect
très large ce que leurs confrères
américains ne semblaient pas s'être
donné la peine de faire tous les proches
de la victime commencent par être
suspectés
les parents ils ont commencé une vraie
enquête
et ont interrogé plus de 70 personnes
moi j'ai été réinterviewé et j'ai été
interviewé en tant que suspect
comme il se doit puisque j'étais un ami
proche tous les proches doivent des
suspects
américains avaient rien fait du tout ils
ont analysé tous les coups de téléphone
analyser son ordinateur
des échantillons qui ont été analysés au
laboratoire de la police scientifique à
Paris
et les premiers résultats d'analyses des
laboratoires français ne vont pas tarder
à conforter la thèse du meurtre
d'abord contrairement à ce qu'affirmer
la police américaine Hugues n'avait pas
pris de drogue le soir de sa mort
la police américaine voulait pousser la
théorie du suicide sous l'emprise de
stupéfiant et heureusement il n'avait
pas pris de drogue
plus surprenant encore ces analyses
scientifiques vont également révéler une
chose incroyable concernant le fameux
couteau à steak retrouvé chez Hugues
dans la cuisine
depuis le début on prend pour argent
comptant que sur le couteau il y a des
tâches de sang donc c'est l'arme du
crime puisqu'il y a du sang sur le
couteau or à l'analyse il a fallu
attendre je ne sais combien de temps
pour ça à l'analyse on s'aperçoit que
c'est du ketchup
la police a pris du simple ketchup pour
du sang
les lacunes de l'enquête américaine
éclatent alors au grand jour
d'autant que la lame de ce couteau ne
correspond pas aux blessures de la
victime
[Musique]
d'après le médecin légiste français
l'arme du crime serait plutôt un couteau
de chasse
[Musique]
la thèse du suicide de Hugues de la
Plaza vient donc d'être officiellement
récusé la police de San Francisco est
montrée du doigt
[Musique]
il fonctionnaires de police américaines
qui avaient été chargé de ce dossier
ont finalement été dessaisies
et envoyé à la douane des aéroports
pour François de la Plaza et les proches
de Hugues c'est une revanche grâce au
travail des enquêteurs français ils vont
être en mesure de savoir avec précision
comment leur fils et amis a vécu ces
dernières heures
[Musique]
parce que la police américaine n'avait
pas fait la police française va le faire
à savoir analyser l'ordinateur analyser
le téléphone et l'exploiter savoir
quelles sont les derniers appels et
accessoirement les SMS
grâce aux informations collectées les
enquêteurs savent que le jeune ingénieur
du son passe la journée du vendredi à
son travail
puis qu'il quitte son bureau il est 17
heures
il rentre chez lui après son travail et
cet après-midi
rentre donc chez lui vers 22h
mais il n'y reste pas et que vous voulez
sortir ce soir
[Musique]
là c'est d'avoir une conversation avec
lui au bar il avait les dents blanches
et le tarot il est heureux il souriait
elle avait un peu bu
le fonds
voici la toute dernière photo de Hugues
de la Plaza prise par l'un de ses amis
quelques minutes avant sa mort
il est deux heures du matin
l'établissement ferme tout le monde sort
du bar
les amis de Hugues proposent de
prolonger la soirée ailleurs mais le
jeune homme refuse il a d'autres projets
expliquent-ils
sur Internet
[Musique]
Hugues et bel et bien rentré chez lui
directement après avoir quitté ses amis
l'analyse de son ordinateur va apporter
une précision horaire il est deux heures
18 quand il allume son appareil
il se connecte alors à un site de
rencontre
mais une demi-heure plus tard il se
passe quelque chose d'étrange
les policiers français ont été capables
de déterminer que l'ordinateur a été
coupé
en effet à 2h40 précisément le câble
d'alimentation est débranché de façon
inopinée ce qui va engendrer un message
d'erreur
j'ai débranché d'une manière anormale
d'après
pourquoi c'est pas
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il ce samedi 3 juin 2016
dans l'appartement de la Plaza à deux
heures 40
pourquoi le câble de son ordinateur
a-t-il été comme arraché
une chose est certaine le français était
bel et bien vivant jusqu'à cette
heure-ci
[Musique]
après avoir reconstitué l'emploi du
temps de la victime les policiers
français vont réinterroger les voisins
de Hugues de la Plaza et ils vont faire
une incroyable découverte
le propriétaire du garage bleu situé à
gauche de la résidence du jeune homme a
fait installer il y a quelques années un
dispositif de vidéo surveillance
[Musique]
il y avait plusieurs caméras vidéos
particulières
aussi invraisemblable que cela puisse
paraître les policiers américains
n'avaient pas exploité l'enregistrement
cependant en visionnant les bandes les
Français vont déchanter
[Musique]
seule la caméra à l'ouest fonctionnait
et on l'a visionnant les enquêteurs
découvrent qu'à deux heures 16 un
individu se dirige vers l'immeuble duc
de la Plaza
[Musique]
il y a une ombre qui passe et on croit
reconnaître Hugues mais on voit rien
d'autre
les enquêteurs s'interrogent alors et si
le tueur avait échappé à l'objectif cela
est possible car cette caméra de vidéo
surveillance est un peu particulière
[Musique]
elle ne filme en réalité qu'une image
toutes les quatre secondes
si quelqu'un en passant très vite
n'aurait pas eu le temps de passer sans
être filmé
d'autant que le champ de cette caméra ne
s'étend pas jusqu'au perron de
l'appartement de Hugues
et se dirigent vers sa porte la caméra
ne couvre pas cette partie quelqu'un qui
passe la traverse la rue selon les trois
en face c'est pas il est pas il est pas
sanctionné par la caméra
sur les images vidéos les enquêteurs
français pensent donc qu'il s'agit bien
de Hugues de la Plaza
cela prouve que le jeune homme est bien
seul lorsqu'il rentre chez lui à 2h16
alors une nouvelle piste se dessine si
le tueur a évité de se montrer à la
caméra c'est peut-être qu'il connaissait
les lieux et qu'il pourrait s'agir d'un
proche de Hugues mais alors qui
[Musique]
les enquêteurs vont vite s'apercevoir
qu'en réalité il y a des personnes qui
pouvaient en vouloir à la victime car
Hugues faisait des jaloux étant donné
qu'il avait énormément de relations
féminines ont dit bon il est peut-être
tombé sur un mari jalon ça ne le gênait
pas que ce soit la petite amie ou la
femme de quelqu'un donc
[Musique]
la mauvaise personne c'est évidemment de
la spéculation
et se débarrasser du couteau
parmi les rideaux potentiels de Hugues
un homme va attirer l'attention des
enquêteurs
il s'agit de Marco Lacito le manager de
la victime avec lequel il entretenait
d'ailleurs des relations pour le moins
compliqué il y avait une très grande
rivalité entre eux et je me demande s'il
y avait pas des histoires de femmes
entre eux Hugues de la Plaza et une
relation sexuelle ou sentimentale avec
la femme de ce collègue de travail c'est
la thèse qui nous a le plus longtemps
possible
et pour cause
interviewée en 2010 lors d'une émission
de télévision américaine consacrée au
meurtre
Marco Lacito n'est pas très tendre avec
son ex collègue
jouer le petit français
on peut le dire
Marco Lacito est-il pour autant impliqué
dans la mort de Hugues de la Plaza les
policiers français ne trouveront aucun
élément à charge contre lui
tout ça n'est qu'une rumeur et
vérification faite ça semble
complètement impossible
à savoir si vous ne savez pas que vous
ne soyez chef psychopathe
ce n'est pas Marco Lacito alors qui a
tué le jeune Français
un début de réponse ne se fait pas
attendre car les derniers résultats
d'analyses des laboratoires français
viennent justement de tomber sur le
bureau des enquêteurs
la découverte français
[Musique]
faute de temps et faute de moyens on ne
saura jamais à qui appartient cet ADN et
sans preuve tangible ni piste sérieuses
pour nommer un suspect crédible l'équipe
française doit se résoudre à rentrer en
France
quand ils sont reparti moi j'ai suivi je
les ai d'ailleurs rencontré les
policiers à Paris aussi
[Musique]
qui nous ont dit bon offre un pas
officiellement mais offre une maison dit
que eux ils étaient persuadés que
c'était un assassinat
qui comprenait pas comment le SFPI
travailler
mais que malheureusement ils avaient pas
de preuves tangibles
pourtant pas question de baisser les
bras voilà maintenant plus d'un ancug le
fils de François est mort et la vérité
n'a toujours pas été établie le père est
pleurer va donc tenter le tout pour le
après le départ des enquêteurs français
François de la Plaza décide de se battre
avec les armes américaines
il offre une récompense 100000 dollars
soit près de 90 000 euros à qui
fournirait des informations sur cette
affaire
le père de la victime placard des
affiches dans tous San Francisco
qui permettrait de trouver les coupables
[Musique]
et je pense que c'était la bonne chose à
faire
d'ailleurs cette récompense va faire
éclore une nouvelle hypothèse et
peut-être un nouveau suspect
la dernière hypothèse c'est un crime de
l'intérieur c'est à dire un crime commis
par un voisin qui n'a ni à rentrer ni à
sortir de l'immeuble
si serait séduisant comme hypothèse
puisque la vidéo n'a filmé personne
d'autre que Hugues de la Plaza rentrant
chez lui
[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre cette piste il
suffit de regarder la résidence où
vivait de la Plaza
au rez-de-chaussée à gauche de
l'appartement de Hugues il y a
titanjalibuchane et son compagnon
au premier étage à droite Guy un jeune
homme célibataire souvenez-vous celui
qui a découvert les tâches de sang sur
le perron
enfin l'appartement situé au premier
étage à gauche est habité par un
électricien Craig qui vit avec son
compagnon et c'est Craig qui va
justement attirer les suspicions car
l'appel à témoin va porter ses fruits
c'est le détective privé payé par le
père de la victime qui a reçu un étrange
appel
[Musique]
ce mystérieux informateur dit-il vrai
vous souhaite-t-il seulement toucher la
prime en dénonçant gratuitement Craig le
voisin
Murphy le détective privé décide
d'enquêter sur les deux hommes du
premier étage
ils étaient un peu fou il vivait dans
l'appartement depuis très longtemps
probablement depuis les années 70
une fois j'étais au travail et mon mari
m'appelle de la maison pour me dire
est-ce que je dois appeler la police
parce que l'un des deux hommes au-dessus
est en train de crier l'autre pleure et
l'inconnu va tuer l'autre
voisin instable aurait-il pu attaquer
Hugues
selon le détective ce serait possible
ce n'est pas tout le détective privé a
découvert que Craig l'électricien ne
quitte jamais un objet très particulier
ce couteau pourrait-il être l'arme du
crime
est-il un suspect potentiel
pour François de la Plaza le père de la
victime
cela ne colle pas
c'est un gros cutter d'électricien pour
dénuyer les fils la lampe du coin a fait
4 cm de largeur donc c'était
incompatible avec les blessures qui
avaient reçu
l'ADN de tous les intervenants parce que
ils n'ont pas le droit ils ne peuvent
relever la bien des personnes que si les
personnes sont d'accord et s'il y a des
motifs sérieux de
suspicion sur ces personnes
alors qui a tué Hugues de la Plaza un
mari jaloux un dealer un voisin drogué
au fil des années certains proches de la
victime ont arrêté de mener l'enquête la
douleur et la lassitude ont eu raison de
leur désir de justice
un moment donné ça m'a tellement énervé
que j'ai décidé d'arrêter le combat quoi
je pense que l'affaire restera
de leur côté en Bretagne François et
Mireille de la Plaza conserve une
détermination intacte on y va comme ça
je sais pas c'est comme quand on marche
dans la forêt on sait pas où on va tout
droit s'il y a un arme la porte quoi on
cherche et tout pose pas de question
comment s'était passé qui avait fait ça
voilà
[Musique]
entre 100 Francisco et la France chaque
année pour récupérer les informations et
chaque année la police américaine refuse
de coopérer avec eux ils disent on est
toujours en train d'enquêter ne vous en
faites pas
vrai
mais François de la Plaza s'accroche il
lui reste un espoir
consiste à explorer
François de la Plaza n'a plus qu'une
corde à son arc sa dernière cartouche
c'est l'ADN retrouver sur la montre de
son fils
[Musique]
qui pourrait être indication
intéressante mais là encore François de
la Plaza se retrouve seul
François essaye par ses propres moyens
de récupérer l'ADN de d'amis de voisins
de tout ça et essaye de faire les
analyses lui-même
il continuera d'enquêter sur la même de
son univers
la récompense de 100000 dollars qui
permettra d'arrêter le meurtrier de
Hugues de la Plaza tient toujours
le prix de la vérité
le prix de la justice